all right so i want to talk about one of themost
common questions we get on the channel
which is:
What is rich?
we get asked this a lot um and uh i think to be
honest often when people ask this the question
they're really asking is do you want to tax me?
because obviously we talk on the channel a lot
about we need to tax the rich more, we need to
tax the rich more and people are basically worried
that it's going to be them that pays more tax so i
think the best way to answer this is basically to
give a kind of accurate description of the wealth
distribution in this country and sort of where we
are as a country um yeah with regards to wealth
and how it's distributed um the first point is
to make you know whenever i talk about taxing
the rich i'm always talking about high wealth
individuals & high wealth families it's not about
high income individuals or high income families
who may not be necessarily high wealth um and i think
that's important because we live in a country now
where housing is very very expensive and that
means that you could be high income you could be
you know a banker like i was or you could be a
lawyer or you could have you know you could work
in some industry making 70-80 grand a year which
is which is much higher than the national average
um and still be actually struggling to
afford a home things like this um and
i'm not at all looking to tax people you know
what i want to create here is a is a country
and a world in which ordinary people can get
jobs work hard get paid have nice properties
have nice lives afford families comfortably um
so when i talk about taxing the rich it's about
high wealth families high wealth
individuals okay it's not about
high income individuals who are not high
wealth you know i think it's i think i mean
if you consider the situation we're in right now
you know i'm i'm not crazy rich and we'll get into
that but i earnt a lot of money in a short amount
of time and i paid 50% tax on everything i made um
which was you know a few million pounds um whereas
at the same time the Duke of Westminster earnt
inherited i think £9,000,000,000 & paid nothing
so we currently live in a system where
people from poor and ordinary backgrounds who
earn decent amounts of money pay very high tax but
people from very very rich backgrounds can earn
unbelievable crazy amounts of money it's important
to realize you know this guy made more than a
thousand times what i made and paid less tax
than me it's pretty crazy right and when you look
at it like that you have to kind of accept that
we actually have quite basically a class-based tax
system whereas people from my sort of background
my sort of voice and you know you don't need to
be from London you could be from wherever Glasgow
or Manchester or Birmingham you know people
from ordinary backgrounds who earn high incomes
sometimes not even crazy high incomes pay 50
percent but people from very wealthy backgrounds
can earn billions and pay nothing so we currently
have a system where we're already taxing
earners but we're not actually taxing these
very wealthy families in many cases at all
so when i say tax the rich i'm talking about
very very wealthy families but then that still
leaves us the question of how wealthy is
wealthy okay so the first thing to say is
this country the uk is actually it has
a reputation as a very unequal country
but if you look you know from an
international or a historical perspective
it's not a massively unequal country compared
to where a lot of countries are or or even
where this country has been in the past so this
country still has a relatively high percentage of
people or families who own their own home you
know i think that owner occupied percentage is
something like 78% um and that that's not the case
in a lot of countries right and it wasn't the case
in this country 100 years ago so what that means
is a lot of people or families do own property
some somewhere in the family it might not be
you it might be your husband it might be your
uh your father you know i mean but a lot of
families own property um and that means that
wealth inequality in this country is not
terribly bad you know if you go to a place like
India which is very high inequality or
Russia which has very high inequality
you'll see that ordinary families
often really struggle to own like
decent properties whereas in this country
there is a lot of property owning people um
but what is happening is increasingly fewer
and fewer people are able to own property
and especially if you look at younger
generations when it comes to owning property like
they need to take really
really really big mortgages
so what that means is generationally
ordinary families are losing wealth um
and then there's a question of where isthat
wealth going so when we talk aboutrich
what is rich? so to be in
the top 1% of richest
people in this country you need
about three and a half million pounds
which is this is quite a lot of money i think you
know three and a half million pounds is a lot um
but one percent of people in this country do
have more than three and a half million pounds um
so really you know often i suggest okay let's tax
people above that level three and a half million
pounds um but i think actually the most important
thing is that you hit the people at the very top
and the reason i say that is if you bring in a tax
that effectively taxes people who are three and
a half million pounds and three and a half million
pounds a lot of money you know if you're worth
three enough million pounds you can afford to pay
more tax um but if you hit those people but
you don't hit say the Rishi Sunak, who is worth
apparently about 700 million pounds and his father
knows worth billions um if you tax people worth
three and a half million pounds and you don't
tax people are worth 700 million pounds then
ultimately that wealth which is currently held
by the three and a half million pound families
will end up being owned by Rishi Sunak and then
other people of that level of wealth you know so i
think really i'm i didn't come into this game as a
with really a moral ethical perspective i'm an
economist and um what i see is is an economy
where wealth is draining away from this you know we
we have a middle class in this country we have a
group of people sort of a middle 50% of people who
can live a comfortable ish life and can accumulate
assets but it's shrinking and their wealth is
moving to the super rich and i i see this economy
and i say okay well if that keeps happening
it's inevitable basically they'll be growing
poverty basically and that's not a good thing and
it's the direction of travel is important right
so if you don't do anything to reverse that then
what you will see is this middle class and you
know this might be a lot of people watching who
they own their own property, you know if it's in
London they're probably like worth a million
pounds you know and maybe they don't have a
massive mortgage on it or maybe they do a mortgage
on it so there's a lot of people in London who
might be worth 500 - 700,000 pounds because
their property values have gone up um these
people will be squeezed out over time and the
way they'll be squeezed out is essentially that
the rich will use their enormous incomes to
buy assets from them um and i think there's
this problem where increasingly because house
prices are so high people who are not actually
rich they don't live lives of luxury think of
themselves as rich because they look at their
net asset their net worth and it's like it could
be a million pounds they could be a millionaire
right um and don't get me wrong you know you
know if you do have a net worth a million pounds
you're in the top two percent of the country you
know i mean you are well richer than average um
but because house prices are going up and up
and up and up and up the only way to access
that money is to sell your house and i think we're
increasingly seeing this interesting dynamic for
ordinary families where they feel rich because
their house is worth a lot of money but there's
no way for them to ever access that money so then
they end up panicking that if i say tax the rich
i mean tax them but the reality of this situation
is if we don't tax the rich they will get your
house in the end you know they will get your
house in the end and they'll push the price up
and up and up and up and up but eventually we'll
not be able to compete with it um so yeah look
i personally where do i sit in all this you
know i'm i'm probably not in that one percent
i'm probably not worth three and a half million
pounds you know i don't see it i don't have a
spreadsheet or anything you know what i mean
um but i would be willing to pay more tax if
the richest paid it as well you need to hit the
top you know and i've said it before in the news
i'll pay if Rishi Sunak pays it but um if you don't hit
these super rich then they will use their enormous
incomes to buy your assets and that is what you're
seeing they'll squeeze you out what we're seeing
increasingly is the middle class being squeezed
out now i know and i want you to think if you if
you own a million pound house even if you're
in a 600,000 pound house i want you to think
what are your kids going to do how are they on you
know regular income is 30-40,000 pounds you know
how are they going to buy a house when houses
cost 600 000 pounds you know what i mean are they
all going to live in your house forever you know
you know this is the situation we are in is that
ordinary people in this country ordinary families
who do have wealth are losing their wealth year
after year generation after generation to the
rich and if that is allowed to continue and and
then they are paying higher rates of tax than
the rich do if that is allowed to continue then it
is inevitable that we will see broad increase and
we will eventually reach a place of mass poverty
in this country which we within 100 years ago
and you know you know go to India go to Russia
and look at what really unequal economies look
like they are economies where ordinary families
live very very difficult lives and
can't own property and if you think
it can't happen here well it happened here
it was like that here 100 years ago and um
you need to look at the direction of travel of
wealth are ordinary people getting richer or are
ordinary people getting poorer are the super rich
getting richer or the super rich is getting poorer&
at the moment we live in a time where ordinary
people are very rapidly losing their wealth
and the rich are very rapidly getting it and you
need to look into the future and say where does
that lead us as a country where does that leave
my family where does that leave my community
and um you know we're going to talk
about different ways that that could be
addressed um i've got some ideas about ways we
can do it to sort of address that balance but
ultimately if you allow wealth to flow from if you
want our wealth to flow from ordinary families to
the rich and you have no mechanism to get wealth
back from the rich to ordinary families then it will
lead to a country of mass poverty and and you
know i've been betting on that happening for 15
years and i've had millions of pounds doing it
um and i think increasingly it's becoming obvious
that that's the direction we're going right you
know half the country won't be able to heat their
homes this winter in 10 years time that would be
70% in 20 years time it will be nearly everyone you
know that's that that is that is what happens if
you allow the people of a country to have all of
their assets taken away from them you know you
need assets you need homes you need food and
if you don't own anything it's going to be very
difficult to get that stuff so um you know i look
at the world distribution and i look at the travel
of it and and and it leads me to see a very bleak
future and and the way to push back into that
is tax the super rich and who is rich to be honest
Rishi Sunak is rich he's worth £700,000,000
listen i'll pay it if he pays it and you know
i don't want any situation where people who are
not rich are paying *HIGHER* rates of taxes people
who are really really [__] rich and that's the
world we live in right now you know and i know
i've made a lot of money and i'm super grateful
but i'm not super rich i don't live a life of luxury
but i paid 50% everything i earned and there's
billionaires in this country who don't pay that
there's billionaires in this country
who paid less than me there's billions
in this country that have paid less
than the people watching this video
and you know if that's the situation that
we have if that's the world that we live in
um yeah the future is going to be very dark indeed
but but we can push back and that's what i'm
trying to do so uh so yeah i would just encourage
people to say look i'm not after i'm not after you
i'm not after houses um you know i'm a relatively
sort of comfortably wealthy person myself um
but i see the direction of traveling on
me to change it so um i support it and i
hope other people do too so yeah
tax the rich, the really rich (good?)
housing could be so much more affordable wages
could be so much higher and we could have so
many more options in how we live our lives some
of them put a lot of money into paying economists
and think tanks to tell you that inequality
is important for the economy that is not true